es el primer periodista estadounidense
arrestado por cargos de espionaje desde
que acabó la guerra fría él dice que es
inocente y Estados Unidos ha exigido su
Liberación inmediata pero Rusia insiste
en que fue sorprendido con las manos en
la masa cuando estaba intentando
recopilar información según Rusia
confidencial y secreta sobre el complejo
militar Industrial ruso en concreto
estaba cerca de una fábrica de tanques
en el catering Burgos también había
estado recopilando en los últimos días
antes de ser detenido información sobre
el grupo de mercenarios Wagner propiedad
de jeffganissin unos mercenarios que
están jugando un papel muy importante en
la Guerra de Ucrania el periódico para
el que trabajaba el Wall Street journal
y también otros medios internacionales
han exigido la liberación del reportero
insistiendo en que se trata de un
periodista en ningún caso de un espía